you're being urged to use caution when
deciding on donations for relief or
other efforts in support of ukraine the
attorney general's office is advising
nevadans about scammers who are
targeting people who are just looking to
make a difference christian gassadis
joining us now in studio with that new
warning tonight christian well denise
the attorney general's office tells us
there are no complaints as of now but
they just want to be proactive to avoid
any problems today they are sharing the
following tips to avoid some headaches
as the war between russia and ukraine
continues americans are opening up their
wallet to help the nevada attorney
general's office warning that criminals
disguising their schemes to get your
money their office would not confirm the
number of complaints but that the alert
is a proactive approach according to the
attorney general's office nevadans need
to be on alert and watch for the
following donating to a crowdfunding
platform only give to organizations you
trust be careful giving out your
personal and financial information like
your social security or bank number
the state is also stressing everyone
should read all the policies and only
make the generous act if you know or
trust the person or the company
organizing the campaign
finally when in doubt cross check any
organization with watchdog groups like
charity watch charity navigator or the
better business bureau to confirm the
charity has an a rating
well if you've fallen victim to a scam
you can file a complaint with the
federal trade commission or the nevada
attorney general's office now if it's an
online charity you we have a breakdown
of go to resources on our website eight
newsnow dot com christian casa is live
local now